It's widely known as China's North Pole.
The city of Mohar,
the furthest
north in the country,
has experienced its coldest day
ever, -53 degrees Celsius.
Or -63.4 degrees Fahrenheit on S
coming
just months
after China saw its worst heat
wave in more than 50 years.
With climate change,
we certainly expect that the ext
are going to be somewhat worse
than they were before.
And this applies
especially to the temperatures
and the precipitation
Extreme cold is having a deadly
in Afghanistan,
exacerbated by limited
humanitarian aid being distribut
After the ruling,
Taliban banned
female aid workers
from operating in the country.
At least
157 people have lost their lives
according to a Taliban official.
The death
toll doubling in
just the last week
Around 70,000
livestock are frozen to death.
This is an extreme situation
at the moment
that we're
facing with subzero temperatures
in many of our areas of operatio
And families
that are already
have been pushed to the brink
for survival
due to the economic crisis are e
more dire straits.
A wave of extreme cold has
spread through Northeast Asia.
Subzero temperatures
moving in from Siberia,
stranding thousands of travelers
at airports in parts of South Ko
And Japan
for the end of the Lunar
New Year holiday.
Heavy snow is continuing
to disrupt flights
in Japan, with hundreds
being canceled Tuesday and Wedne
Videos posted on social media
showed treacherous conditions.
One focus for experts is the wid
between seasons toilet of Seattl
That I'll tell you
if the difference
between the highest
and lowest temperatures
during a year
used to be about 40 degrees Cels
The difference can be 60 degrees
these days.
The cold weather means
the extreme points will be very
One climate change
expert says looking wider
than the extreme cold in North E
paints a very interesting patter
The distinctive thing,
if you look at it on a hemispher
is that it's extraordinarily war
in the North Pacific,
up into southern Alaska,
and it's extraordinarily warm
in the North Atlantic,
all the way
up through Norway
and Sweden and Iceland
and even further north.
Extreme cold in north east
Asia, at least, is expected to e
in coming days.
Paula Hancocks, CNN, Seoul.